okay I'm going to suggest to you today
that we start referring to Donald
Trump's tariffs as tax increases on
everyday Americans because that's what
they actually are in practice and that's
something I thought that Republicans
claim to be against and I've been
talking about this since Donald Trump's
tariffs on China were just an idea now
there are a reality as I told you in the
last segment new tariffs have been
announced on Mexico those start at 5%
potentially escalating all the way up to
25% according to Donald Trump if you
believe that that is actually what he is
going to do now it's really important to
understand and I feel like a broken
record with this China doesn't pay the
tariffs that Donald Trump placed on them
Mexico will not pay the tariffs that
Donald Trump is placing on them is in
the process of placing on them the
tariffs on China and Mexico make their
stuff more expensive to import to the
United States so when you import it you
pay China or Mexico the same amount for
their stuff plus you pay something to
the United States government in addition
to that a tariff it is effectively it is
effectively a tax Trump has said many
times his tariffs are forcing China to
pay however many billions of dollars
that's just not how it works if China
has $100 product that the United States
buys and you put a twenty five percent
tariff on Chinese goods the American
company or person who buys the hundred
dollar thing from China is still paying
China just the hundred bucks and then in
addition to that they pay the US
government 25 bucks in the case of a
hypothetical 25 percent tariff
what this means is that the American
company or the American person paying
the tariff on the Chinese stuff ends up
with twenty five dollars that they could
have spent at local businesses could
have spent in other ways within the
American economy but they don't have
those 25 bucks because they paid it to
the government as a tariff I thought
that small government low tax
conservatives were against that and they
wanted Americans to keep
more of their own money in order to do
whatever they want in order to stimulate
local business this is bad for the
United States this boycott this I'm
sorry this tariff program is crushing
soybean exports which are down 97
percent from 2017 in the United States
Trump's tariffs are crushing whiskey s
exports because of the retaliatory
tariffs that are put in place
whiskey s exports down 32% in the fourth
quarter of 2018 compared to the fourth
quarter of 2017 and unfortunately this
is the most disgusting part of it all
Donald Trump genuinely doesn't seem to
understand the basics of how tariffs
work and it's not actually super
shocking that it's not being corrected
because Trump's administration has no
serious or credible economics people
remaining there's this guy Larry Kudlow
who Trump seems to ignore anyway and
whose opinion Trump has previously
disavowed when it wasn't in line with
what Donald Trump wanted to believe look
at the tweet that Donald Trump posted
over the weekend quote in order not to
pay tariffs if they start rising
companies will leave Mexico which has
taken 30% of our auto industry and come
back home to the United States Mexico
must take back their country from the
drug lords and cartels the tariff is
about stopping drugs as well as illegals
it I I'm almost at a loss for words
because Mexican companies aren't going
to leave Mexico to avoid paying the
tariffs because they don't pay the
tariffs
it's the Americans paying the tariffs
when they buy or import Mexican stuff
Donald Trump has weaponized his ignorant
on this issue and probably on some
others remember when he called his now
indicted national security advisor
Michael Flynn in the middle of the night
to ask him hey Michael is a strong
dollar or a weak dollar good for the
United States
remember when Trump campaigned endlessly
on how he was going to fix health care
which he didn't by the way and then it
was revealed through something Trump
said at one of his speeches that he
seemed confused between health insurance
and life insurance he confused the two I
won't rehash the whole story we've done
a couple of segments about it I know we
already talked about the Mexican tariffs
but the Mexico tariff idea is incredible
in how massively negative it's going to
be for everybody tariffs on Mexican
stuff will make things more expensive
for Americans which is not good for the
economy for the American economy it will
potentially hurt the Mexican economy
which will push more Mexicans to want to
come to the United States whether it's
legally or illegally which is what
Donald Trump claims to want to stop so
number one we've got to start calling
these tariffs taxes maybe we call it an
excise tax since excise taxes are taxes
on specific goods or services like you
pay excise tax on a car for example or
on specific activities sometimes excises
are paid I don't know that his base will
notice or care they probably see Trump
putting tariffs on Mexico like the idea
of oh we're hurting brown people and
that's a good thing I don't know but
we've got to change the language around
it it's getting really bad make sure you
follow us on instagram at david pakman
show quick break back after this